I need to talk about your dress tell me
about why you picked an orange chakras
you is pretty with a pretty color it fit
nice I just love it I love this dress I
feel like it's it's soft and it's a
little hard and it's kind of like me
performing tonight yes there were her
CIL's vanessa was here before I saw a
little bit on Instagram this is
emotional it's a CEO song it is it is I
I feel so blessed to have you know how
to co-write this song for this movie
everything that it's about I'm excited
for people to see the performance
tonight it's for me this movie in this
song is about the world beats right now
and I I'm just so proud that I get to do
it super excited so excited I'm here my
Cola star I'm it's just an amazing night
the message of this movie correct me if
I'm wrong is really about that there is
no limit for women and we go and we can
do it all that's right it's very much
the Jennifer Lopez it is it is kind of
my message as well but that's the only
thing holding you back is you you can do
anything you want that we are limitless
all we have to do is scream and let our
voices out stand up for what we believe
in it's it's just it's so timely right
now and I'm like I said I'm so excited
to be able to be the person to bring it
tonight that type of message I'm excited
I just don't even know what to say I'm
excited and what I told Vanessa is that
and I've told my low as well I need a
rom-com in my life yes I have been
missing this this is the holiday rom-com
that you had you been waiting for I've
been breaking I hate one you know these
are my favorite kinds of movies I love
the maid of Manhattan's and me and the
wedding planners and the monster in-laws
in there and I haven't done one of these
in a long time so it's it's again super
exciting for me I know your honor 900th
act because you do so many things even
though this is second act but if there
was a second half for you what would you
is there another dream is there a dream
left to dream with you I have a lot of
dreams I have a lot of
still I think you have to keep you know
finding a new purpose finding a new
excitement finding a new passion in your
life that's what keeps life interesting
and I have so many things that I still
want to do so many things